freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ich freue mich schon lange darauf
denn wir machen heute pasta und zwar
nicht irgendwie sondern in einem ganzen
laib käse ist hier drin und es ist
ziemlich schwer zehn kilo hat er fragt
warum was für eine verrückte idee ist
hat einen ganz bestimmten grund und zwar
wurde ich vom sanjay gemeinsam mit der
eu an gefragt ob ich lust habe
französischen käse näher zu bringen um
eine community und natürlich habe ich
lust darauf ich meine wie geil ist das
ich kann einfach mit absoluten premium
käse arbeiten und coole videos darüber
wachen so brenner und wir packen das
gute stück hier mal aus und
währenddessen erzähle ich euch was ich
damit überhaupt vorhabe wir werden es
heute nämlich relativ simpel halten ich
werde nämlich nichts weiter benutzen
simpel als trüffel diesen käse ansonsten
sondern auch rohöl wird glaube ich eine
sehr sehr leckere angelegenheit und der
käse geht es hier drin befindet ist ein
kernteil und wirklich nudeln im käse
live wollte ich schon macht und seitdem
ich da zum ersten mai von gehört habe
ich bestelle die events ist im
restaurant geschlecht immer frische
trüffel es wird einfach nur geil
und jetzt holen wir ihn raus hier ist
das gute stück und dass das gut ist ihr
seht schon der kampagne ist ein wenig
kleiner als herkömmliche hartkäse die
man bei dieser art von passt aber wird
was heißt super chillig ist weil so ist
das überhaupt erst möglich in einem
privaten rahmen wenn man keine ahnung
der familienfeier hat oder sowas dann
holt man sich so ein ding und dann kann
man den ganzen lieben langen tag lang
käse passt da machen wir machen das auch
ohne wir feiern heute
das ist schon etwas was feines sohn
ganzen käselaibe zu hause in der
privaten küche das ist irgendwie echt
schiss und der auch wirklich eine sehr
schöne größe hier ist es also unser
prachtstück aber bekommen wir damit
anfangen und den aufschneiden auch wir
erstmal hier unsere knoblauchzehen ich
werde nämlich knoblauch konfi machen
ganz einfach aber wunderschön und soll
auch sehr sehr lecker sein und zwar
schneiden wir einfach bei einer großen
knoblauch knolle einfach oben gehe ich
ab so dass quasi die oberseiten von 1
knoblauchzehe freigelegt sind ich habe
ein bisschen frischen rosmarin und
thymian geholten jetzt brauchen wir alle
folien gehen dann unsere knoblauch
bisher darauf geben ordentlich olivenöl
drüber
v8 dann meersalz drüber
frischen pfeffer
thymian und rosen bringen so nehmen wir
dann das ganze und machen daraus ein
kleines paket das erstes verpackt und
zweiter kümmern wir uns jetzt und dann
können wir das ganze 40 minuten bei 200
grad in den ofen
[Musik]
wäre jetzt also 40 minuten zeit um
unseren pasta und käse zu kümmern und
wir müssen wir jetzt zuallererst mal
öffnen ich habe extra so ein käse draht
für geholt mit dem man das öffnen soll
deutsche essen können soll bevor wir
jetzt mit unserem draht reingehen
probiere ich einmal so eine kleine kerbe
in cannes teil rein zu machen ich habe
keine ahnung was hier gerade wasser weil
es oft macht man sowas schon das kommt
mir ein bisschen rein dann auch
probieren dort daran zu setzen mit dem
draht da quasi reinzuziehen genau und
dann muss ich nicht da jetzt langsam
durch arbeiten
so macht man das professioneller weise
hältst du ihn einfach so quasi von vorne
hier hinten fest dass er mir nur nicht
wegrollt so weißt du
das geht ja richtig gut und bei der
bereits heute eröffnen unseren käse land
wo mein gott das triebwerk rang das rief
vor allem das riecht vor allem soll das
könnte richtig gut klappen das können
also wirklich sehr sehr geil leute die
sich ganz ganz anders als er von innen
richter richtig würzig salzig aber
trotzdem relativ mild auch das ist
nichts was ein so erschlägt und wir
müssen da jetzt wohl ein bisschen
rausnehmen um eine coole rheins machen
wir unsere passt also das jetzt so wie
jetzt habe ich bekommen das geht wie
butter wir kamen jetzt quasi einmal ein
bisschen zu einer form aus eine wohl in
der wir gleich unsere pastor und man
merkt allein jetzt schon von der
konsistenz dass wir so perfekt schmelzen
gleich oder die heiße pasta selbst
gemachte frische pasta wein kommt und
sagt du hast du gute form oder das muss
man mal abwarten wie viel liebe wie viel
handwerk in diesem käsereien fließt den
mann als ganzes jetzt weil sich auf dem
tisch stehen hat und probieren kannst
also das recht wirklich so mild würzig
so irgendwie willst du musst auch
probieren das schmecken
da geht schon fast schon ich das nicht
sagen dass so lange probiert es eine
coole da rein zu machen und dann sehen
wir uns gleich wenn ich hoffentlich
geschafft habe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so leute es ist vollbracht die letzten
bisschen werden rausgeholt und guckt
euch mal bitte alleine an was dieses
loch an käse ist den kann man natürlich
dann später auch noch rein schon
informationen ich werde auch später noch
freunde einladen und wir machen es pasta
party aber geht euch das mal bitte wie
ergiebig so ein laib käse ist und da
drin gleich schön die nudeln fertig
machen ich bin schon sehr geil vorne
rechts geil nach käse hinten kommt schon
der duft von knoblauch aus dem backofen
was soll ich sagen ich muss auf jeden
fall es auszuprobieren weil sonst bin
ich recht hatte wir machen jetzt die
pasta ich mach doch mal den deckel drauf
hier auf unseren kann teil sehr
praktisch auf jeden fall das ganze und
was dich noch mal sagen möchte das ist
für mich normal das ist auch was
besorgen oder für mich und es ehrt mich
auch mit sowas arbeiten zu können in der
küche und euch sowas zu zeigen ich gehe
natürlich davon aus dass es gut wird
aber ich muss auch ehrlich sagen ich
mach das natürlich zum ersten mal und es
jetzt kein step by step rezept was ihr
folgen könnt und zur seite damit und wir
machen jetzt dazu eine pasta aber um den
käse zu ehren machen wir das ganze nur
mit geben die haben aber schon oft
gesehen wie ich das ganze mache deshalb
empfehlen
[Musik]
unsere frische pasta ist fertig und
sieht wunderbar aus hier drüben das
jetzt einfach heiß werden wir machen
nämlich schnell eine butter knoblauch
sahnesoße was soll ich noch sagen leute
das wird einfach nur krass pula money
ohne jojo ich hab grad schon die
konsistenz gefühlt man muss dazu sagen
wundert euch nicht wenn wir jetzt eine
ganze knolle von dem knoblauch in die
soße reinhauen knoblauch konfi verliert
diese schärfe diese krasse bitterkeit
und diesem heftigen knoblauch geschmack
man hat viel mehr dieses geile herzhafte
noch dann nehmen wir uns einen kleinen
kleines stück butter das kann nur noch
gut werden es geht nicht anders so leute
jetzt wird's ernst guckt euch das einmal
an
[Musik]
unser knoblauch von vier röhren wir
jetzt einfach einfluss dir das mal an
darauf kommt jetzt uns zu binden ein
wenig mehl und einzudecken dann auch
freunde das ist kochen ganze knoblauch
neuen ganze käselaibe selbst gemachte
nudeln lanciert und darauf kommt jetzt
ein wenig sahne die wir dann reduzieren
werden wo das ist vorbei es ist vorbei
wo war ich
kann nicht beschreiben wie sehr ich mich
darauf freue dass gleich zu essen aber
das muss jetzt erstmal aufkochen die
arbeit mit drei truppe erzeugnissen
einmal mit einem partie erinnert euch
vielleicht an unserer messe video haben
wir sowas auch gesehen wenn wir ein
trüffelöl und frische trüffel wer es
nicht wusste frische trüffel schmeckt
gar nicht mal so sehr nach dem
künstlichen grippe geschmack der mann
trennen wollen nochmal und dieses öl
hier ne war richtig teuer 16 50 die
flasche hat so ein krankes truppe aroma
damit werde ich richtig vorsichtig sein
eine kranke konsistenz nicht
oder das ist schon so eine kranke soße
die süße es wird eine süße wie der
knoblauch bekommt ist nicht von dieser
welt sah pasta
nehmen wir uns so wie sie ist alles auf
einmal und ab in den topf braucht
überhaupt nicht lange gerade bei
frischer pasta eine gute idee wenn man
das dem man sie in den topf gegeben hat
kräftig umrührt gut dass ich alles lösen
kann bauen die hat wirklich eine schöne
farbe und kaum ist es essen fast fertig
wir auch schon die französin nudel
probieren
heute haben wir das gemacht sagte
ehrlich und es wird zeit für die
hochzeit von käse süßes und nudeln schön
ein bisschen nudelwasser dran auf
unseren angetriebenen konnte es gibt so
eine richtig schöne satisfaction oder
und gleich richtig perversen du weißt
genau was jetzt passieren wird du wirst
jetzt auch wer jetzt jetzt sehen bist du
bereit
fluten das
also selber geflutet erst neu und jetzt
wünschen wir dass alles wir heben jetzt
nudeln hoch ich konnte unsere heiße soße
unten an den konnte schmilzt ihn und
macht das ganze noch mal extra cremig
wie sie um himmels willen leute achtung
achtung achtung
hey leute economo leute ich bin mir
jetzt gerade sicher dass das vielleicht
nicht die leckerste ich habe es probiert
aber dieses taxis der passt da ist
nichts gemacht habe
[Musik]
leute das haben wir da gemacht oder
älter wir haben es gerade ein bisschen
gefreut es war leider ein kleiner
struggle so ihr habt nicht alles gesehen
wie wir es so hübsch gemacht haben aber
es ist ein traum mit den grünen dass es
petersilie dazu frisch gehobeltem
trüffel jetzt probiert
ich probiere
um himmels willen burg war wirklich
diese käsige not und ich habe ja die
soße grad abgeschmeckt dieser käse der
dann noch dazukommt ist so wichtig um so
geil und ich esse gerade das habe ich
mir die ganze zeit so vorgestellt
wirklich will das schon so lange machen
so ein video deshalb hat es so gut
gepasst mit der kooperation
ich will schon so lange sohnes wo ihr
pasta essen und jetzt habe ich sehr
ähnlich
ich habe glaube ich noch nie und das
sage ich jetzt nicht fürs video ich habe
euch noch nie so eine cremige pasta
gegessen es könnte einen 500 gramm käse
gegners könnte an dem halben liter daran
gelegen das kommt auch an der stange
butter liegen aber in jedem fall ist das
hier eine sache die muss man gegessen
das ist pervers das wirklich verwehrt
das ist das verrückteste was hier
gemacht habe in der küche oder ich habe
ihn käselaibe außerdem ich direkt es in
dem ich gerade die krasseste pasta
zubereitet haben sie wirklich supergut
gewordene damit nur eines heftig wird
sagen du musst jetzt auch probieren
ja shit leute wirklich ich bin glücklich
und ich bin ab sagt das ist so mächtig
wir haben da zu dritt die ganze portion
verspeist und es ist wirklich kein spaß
also ich hatte riesige hunger weil das
kochen hat schon so appetit gemacht aber
wir haben es gerade so geschafft das
ganze noch mal fürs unterstützung des
videos das kann noch weitere wilde
videos mit dem französischen
milchindustrie verband und der eu
deshalb freut euch drauf ich freu mich
drauf und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
video
[Musik]